I would like to start with your main
expert opinions and then go through
those can you please tell the jury what
your main opinions were
um so like I said there are opinions
embedded within them but the main
opinion is that misheard's report of
intimate partner violence and the
records that I reviewed is consistent
with what we know in the field about
intimate partner violence characterized
by physical violence psychological
aggression sexual violence coercive
control and surveillance behaviors
and what was the other uh main opinion
that you had
um the second main opinion was that
um that miss her demonstrated very clear
psychological and traumatic effects or
the exacerbation of Trauma from those
statements that Mr debt made through his
attorney there were three statements
that we evaluated to see how they
affected her emotionally and
psychologically and it was in my
determination that they did
and did you arrive at any diagnostic
conclusions yes I did and what were
those I diagnosed misheard with
post-traumatic stress disorder
what if any etiology was associated with
the post-traumatic stress disorder so
the etiology is the cause in order to
have a to meet criteria for
post-traumatic stress disorder you have
to have an actual cause it's one of the
few diagnoses diagnostic entities that
we have to have a cause for and the
cause was the intimate partner violence
by Mr Depp that was the what was pushing
the symptoms that was what's related to
the intrusive phenomena that was related
to her avoidance that was elated to her
differences in her mood that was related
to her avoidance efforts so it was the
the cause was the intimate partner of
Violence by Mr death let's turn back to
intimate partner violence what types of
physical violence were reported to you
um so there were a number of physically
violent behaviors that were reported
um that miss her reported that Mr Depp
perpetrated
um he pushed her he shoved her he
slapped her with the front of his hand
in the back of his hand
um he choked her he slammed her into the
wall he pushed her and she fell down he
kicked her in the back
um
again without looking at my notes that's
the what I can recall okay and what type
of injuries did Amber Heard report to
you she reported mostly
um bruising pain Some Cuts she reported
vaginal pain from some of the sexual
assaults she reported that she did have
some scratches and cuts on her from
broken glass she reported that she
believed she may have lost Consciousness
two times once in the Australia incident
and once in the December 15th 2015
incident so you concluded that Amber
Heard used psychological abuse and some
reactive physical violence I think I
heard you say is that correct objection
leading overruled
can you please explain to the jury what
you meant by that yes that is correct
that um you know Amber Heard reported to
me
um some of the behaviors that she used
that were psychologically aggressive
um the name calling the putting him down
and calling him
um very bad names and insulting his his
fatherhood and she was very shamed and
remorseful about that she also indicated
you know using and as some of the
testing showed minor forms of violence
pushing shoving
um throwing objects we see that a lot
with um women when there's not
proportional Force women are more likely
to throw objects and then the more
severe Act of of punching him which a
punch falls in the more severe category
and and the context as she explained it
was that he was coming after Whitney and
she stood her sister and she stood in
the way and she punched him
no
does that make uh Amber Heard a
perpetrator of intimate partner violence
objection leading
overruled so so that was one of the
tasks that I had to consider that was
one of the hypotheses that I had to
consider and given all of the other data
um that was not my opinion now what if
any
observations did you make about
uh the impact of Mr Depp's substance
abuse
so the substance abuse was a very
relevant and and complicating factor to
this relationship when you pair that
level of substance abuse with the level
of intimate partner violence and
coercive control it's a very very
disastrous mix what if any Dynamics and
coping styles are connected to the
substance abuse by Mr Depp
so they share similarities there's a lot
of lying when somebody's a substance
abuser there's a lot of hiding there's a
lot of concealment there's a lot of
rationalization there's a lot of blame
blaming your partner for your inability
to stay clean and sober there's a lot of
the promises to change and and the
promises to get better so a lot of these
Dynamics sort of co-occur you know in a
situation of of substance abuse and
domestic violence they're very similar
the difficulty in this relationship was
that the majority of the violent
episodes and the sexually violent
episodes were in these alcohol and
drug-fueled rages that was predominantly
when those happened when he wasn't in
those stages we still saw the obsessive
jealousy and the course of control and
the possessiveness that still persisted
but when the alcohol and the drugs came
together is when Amber Heard was more in
in danger of being hurt by him